[Music]
welcome back to curious archive this
video is the second part of a two-part
series exploring the incredible
speculative biology project of snyad a
planet teeming with incredible alien
life snyde was created by cm koziman an
exceptional artist and the creator of
all tomorrows and as usual i have links
below where you can follow and support
his work when we left off we'd visited
many of the basic life forms on snyad
now it's time to study aliens of greater
sizes and stranger biology in a journey
that will reveal secrets from snyad's
mysterious past and perhaps its
unexpected future with humans and even
some never-before-seen images from
kozaman's upcoming book so let's get
started
beginning on the curious island of mapag
something on the beaches is walking
upright on two legs this is an armless
bloomberman a creature whose facial
pouch in which it is currently carrying
its baby is so pronounced it looks
almost humanoid are the armless
bloomberman snyad's approximation of
intelligent life not quite these bipedal
oddities are actually closer to earth
penguins than they are to us as they're
cumbersome on land but better adapted
for the water but the intelligence of
these creatures isn't distinct from
other animals on snyad indeed the author
imagines no species currently living on
the planet's surface possess advanced
intellect but looking into the
archaeological record of snyad there's
evidence that intelligence may have
existed in the distant past according to
cozumen 30 million year old stone axe
heads have been discovered but there's
no clues as to their origins and
metallic artifacts of an apparently
artificial nature called the decided
screws have been dated to even earlier
as snyat is almost twice as old as earth
it seems that perhaps civilization has
risen multiple times only to be
obliterated and erased by mass
extinctions but all this is uncertain
the creatures that currently wander
across nyad however are truly
fascinating regardless of their
intelligence on numerous offshore
islands the beaches are buzzing with the
sounds of grey bloombermen a related
type of bloomba miniform like their
larger cousins these somewhat awkward
looking creatures are also most graceful
under the waves able to chase down
numerous marine organisms almost like
tiny seals hilariously kozaman mentions
the grey bloomberman will one day become
a major symbol in the popular culture of
human settlers and will even form the
basis for cartoon characters and
children's toys that's right humans will
eventually create settlements on snyad
khozman states that in the future of
this narrative human history will become
intertwined with that of snyads as we
create the first settlements on this
alien world
the idea of humans trying to coexist
with these awe-inspiring yet often
terrifying creatures is certainly an
interesting one and one of the most
important future animals to human
settlers is the orca runners mighty
herbivores with distinctive coloring and
a peaceful demeanor thanks to their fast
running speeds and friendly temperament
these unusual creatures will
surprisingly become critical
domesticated animals similar to horses
in the lives of these first settlers
this is a telltale sign that humans and
the planet's fantastical native life
will have a wide range of surprising
interactions
on the subject of fantastical life the
windy crags of the pontic mountains
conceal one of snyad's most spectacular
animals the aptly named spineys possess
four claws first head beaks and dorsal
spines all elongated into javelin-like
spikes despite appearances however the
spineys are herbivorous and have evolved
these spikes purely for defense so
they're actually closer to a hedgehog
than they are to some apex super
predator kozaman imagines human
colonists rarely glimpse spines due to
their shyness instead only hearing the
haunting sounds they produce by rattling
their spikes against each other across
the mainland continent a hulking armored
lifeform is on the move this is the
chasmatorus a type of alatora form an
extremely successful lineage of large
snyaty herbivores unlike its more
amiable cousins however chasmatorus
prefers to be left alone and will charge
down and trample anything that invades
its territory much like an earth
rhinoceros and since they grow to 22
feet or seven meters long their poor
attitude will make them difficult for
colonists to study
in the misty forests of midland a much
smaller organism wanders among the trees
the austro-taurus is an alatora form
which has shrunk considerably due to its
forest habitat and rarely exceeds six
feet or two meters in length far from
defenseless the ostrotorus has evolved
armadillo-like bands of segmented body
armor which keeps the tiny titans safe
from predators like the futatora forms
in all manner of biomes across snyad you
might find that futura forms on the
prowl this particular species is an
arbophobis an animal whose name alludes
to its tree climbing abilities but is
indeed able to conquer most any
environment like most fututura forms
arbophobis is an agile adaptive hunter
similar in many respects to the large
cat species of our own planet indeed the
deadliness of this predator will end up
being its undoing as these fearless
hunters will attack countless settlers
in the early days of human exploration
and as a result the arbophobis will be
purposefully hunted to extinction
but there's another hunter early
settlers will fear even more than the
orbovobus a creature they'll know
through screams on dark knights and the
glints of its huge eyes that is until
cameras reveal these nocturnal organisms
are barely over three feet or one meter
long
called inferno kions these timid hunters
don't deserve their frightening name as
they only use their scissor-like jaws to
feed on small nighttime animals and
simply have unusually loud coals and
large eyes for their body size
in the nearby peaks of oro land a close
relative lives in seclusion these are
the selena khan the largest species of
their order and a critically endangered
one cozumen notes they often hunt near
forest streams at dusk with the starry
sky reflecting off their enormous
haunting eyes it will be a truly sad
loss if these fascinating animals fade
into extinction sometime in snyd's
future
one species with a far more certain
future can be found in abundance north
of the divider mountains this is a
pescadon a bipedal omnivore with a
curious penchant for cooperation one of
the most social animals on snyad
pescadons are known to coordinate hunts
in large family groups with similar
dynamics to wolf packs on earth their
affinity towards social bonding will
make them a favorite domesticated animal
among future human settlers with their
path mirroring that of humans and dogs
if dogs were 10 feet or 3 meters long
that is
upon the elevated plateaus of the
southeast another animal that will have
a key role in humanity's future is
waiting these bizarre spherical
creatures whose first head faces have
become mashed directly into their bodies
are actually the cousins of the
pescodons we just visited and indeed
these hulking heavy beasts are of a
similar size which will make them ideal
draft animals filling a role similar to
earth cows and the lives of the first
settlers
and speaking of early settlers during
the first aerial surveys of snyad vast
paths along the landscape will be
glimpsed and at first assumed to be the
creation of intelligent life in reality
however these lines are the trails of
the unintelligent tractor snakes massive
herbivores of the lofofid classification
who vacuum the land for vegetation like
living combine harvesters at an
astonishing 22 feet or seven meters long
these giants might not be great thinkers
but they're truly impressive shapers of
their environment
at the edge of the enchirion desert a
more modest-sized relative slithers
across the sands this is a phytophyton a
lifeform that at first glance shows a
high degree of convergent evolution with
snakes here on earth unlike all types of
snakes we're familiar with however the
phytophyton isn't a hunter but instead a
generalist herbivore like their larger
tractor snake cousins
if you're looking for a carnivorous
snake analog the sprog land along the
eastern plains contains the closest
thing on snyad say hello to a
chasmatomos a rather odd looking fellow
that is a representative of the poorly
understood sprago fighting
classification while a predator at only
7 inches or 20 centimeters long they're
not the most frightening thing on snyad
yet they do have one truly fascinating
adaptation the ability to shed their
fatty tails when attacked in a strategy
not dissimilar from some types of geckos
unlike geckos however chesmatomo's tales
don't grow back
we've now seen species from all over
snyad and have learned about the future
role they'll play in the lives of human
settlers but there's still one great
frontier we've yet to chart the massive
planetary oceans
taking the common jet shark as our
baseline for underwater life we'll see
the path of life in the oceans is vastly
different from on land the group the jet
shark belongs to the ghetto sets take
the two-headed sniaty body plan in a
highly unexpected direction their first
heads are actually connected to their
digestive tract and their second heads
have become an almost jet like pump
connected to an entirely different
system that's right much of undersea
sniaty life is jet powered kind of like
some species of squids on earth just
taken to a new extreme the jet shark has
found unsurprisingly a niche similar to
a shark in the underwater food chain
but far to the north in the frigid polar
waters you can find a very different
kind of undersea giant meet the
hedrocetoids a 22 feet or 7 meter long
life form that is similarly jet powered
protected from the cold with layers of
thick blubber they travel in large
family pods much like the mighty orcas
that swim through our own oceans unlike
the predacious orcas however the
hadrocetoids are peaceful filter feeders
and elsewhere in the ocean the fantastic
conclusion to our tour of life on snyad
is waiting the xenoposeidon
thalassacaros is a truly awe-inspiring
beast and the largest animal on the
planet at a staggering 130 feet or 40
meters in length their cavernous beaks
have an ingenious system of inlets and
holes that allow them to filter huge
amounts of plankton from the water
giving them the food they need to reach
such incredible sizes of course these
creatures are most similar to earth
whales and their size and feeding
behavior but what relationship will
future humans have with this animal
that's a detail the author has yet to
reveal
indeed many more details regarding snyad
might be revealed later as kozman is
working on a meticulous remake of the
project which thus far has yielded some
incredible reimaginings of familiar
sniadi organisms he gave me a few never
before seen images from the upcoming
book to share which are on the screen
now and in my opinion these new designs
are even better than the old ones so if
you're a fan of this project and like me
really want to see a book someday please
follow and support kozamin in the links
in the description below and as always
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
entry please lend your support and like
subscribe and hit the notification icon
to stay up to date on all things curious
see you in the next video
you